yo what is up everybody this procedure
man Luigi and I'm playing The Witcher 3
and in this video I'm gonna be telling
you guys what I believe is the best way
to gain experience and level up in The
Witcher 3 in terms of a legitimate
method this isn't gonna be an XP exploit
since I don't know of any I do find any
maybe I'll post that but in this this
video it's all about just playing
through the game and what's the best way
to level up and get XP and really the
best way that I found and you might have
heard this before you might not is to do
the main quests and side quests the main
quests even more so than side quests
since in this game you get a very small
amount of xp for killing monsters
compared to what you do for completing
quests some say you finish a main quest
mission basically one of the main quests
you can get anywhere from a hundreds
like 500 XP where as completing a
different quests like a side quest you
can get like 45 maybe if it's a problem
inside question you get like 100 you can
get you can get from 10 to 45 from side
quests like 10 obviously is a very small
amount but like some monsters especially
if they're your level or below will give
you no XP or just a couple XP like
ranging from 1 to like 7 so you can see
main quests the main quest line is the
best 4 if you want to rank up however if
you do only the main quest the other
quests you leave behind are gonna stay
at whatever level um their slaughter
that so if there's level 6 quest and you
love loves level 20 and you go back that
the quest is gonna be level 6 and it is
gonna be kind of laughably easy to do it
so I would suggest the best way to do is
the best way to level up in this game is
to get go through the main quest line
and go through the side quests and just
level up using those so hope you guys
have enjoyed my two cents on what you do
to level up in the witcher 3 which is
just playing through the main and side
quests as you get them basically
whenever you get it just hop in the
quest and do it
so you guys hope you enjoyed if you have
check out my other with your videos I'm
going to be putting more stuff peace out